Before we finish the lesson,
you should know that there are many
Android samples that show off how to use
the notification features
we've just discussed.
Let's go to File > Import Sample,
and bring up the selector.
The first is Basic Notifications.
This is the sample we
first stepped through.
This performs generic notifications for
Android only, and
is a good starting point for testing out
the addition of wearable extensions.
The next is Wearable Notifications.
This sample allows you to generate
every possible notification type for
Android Wear and
see what they look like.
This allows you to prototype
everything before you write the code.
Finally, there is Eliza Chat,
which allows you to have a conversation
using speech recognition with
an artificially intelligent robot,
using your Android Wear
device via notifications.
So give this sample a try to find out
what is possible with Android Wear
notifications.